[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour démarrer la soirée
dans les Yvelines avec au menu de
l'actualité et des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie voici le programme
de ce 12 décembre
plus de 1000 personnes réunies pour la
mémoire de Djibril ce jeune de 14 ans
tué il y a deux semaines dans une rixe à
Coignières une marche blanche s'est
déroulée hier entre le gymnase du moulin
à vent au lieu du drame et la commune de
morpade où était originaire l'adolescent
un moment d'union et d'apaisement sur
lequel nous reviendrons
face à l'inflation ce magasin de
Guyancourt propose des solutions depuis
son ouverture la COP villaroise a mis en
place une offre à prix coûtant la
boutique vend une quarantaine de
produits de base au prix où elle les
achète et l'objectif permet au plus
grand nombre de consommer des denrées
bio et de qualité invités Matthieu
Decroix cogérant de la Coop villaroise
et puis comme tous les lundis les
résultats sportifs du week-end retour
sur la joie des supporters des Bleus
qualifiés pour la demi-finale de la
Coupe du monde de football et beaucoup
d'Yves Linois étaient réunis à Poissy
attrape ce sont les fans du Maroc qui
ont fêté en nombre la victoire dès leur
contre le Portugal samedi soir France et
Maroc s'affrontent mercredi pour une
place en finale
et ce sera dans la page sport tout à
l'heure avec vous Michael en midoro
bonsoir bonsoir journaliste sport de la
rédaction de TV 78 vous allez nous
donner les résultats des des matchs
chinois du week-end de quoi parle-t-on
ce soir on va parler du match nul de
Versailles contre le Red Star c'était en
National de la défaite malheureusement
de Poissy en National 2 et on parlera
également d'un grand champion c'est
Marvin petit qui est avec nous sur ce
plateau Marvin petit qui revient sur le
devant de la scène en boxe c'est bien ça
on va essayer de revenir fort comme
comme avant on va dire après 2 ans et
demi d'absence il faut le rappeler bien
sûr après deux ans et demi d'absence
c'était dur je croyais complètement
arrêté parce que je me suis dit que le
covid ça va c'est mort j'ai plus de
compétition de combat
après voilà je me suis sacrifié dans la
société de couverture que j'ai et puis
des années et j'ai bien fait évoluer ma
société donc du coup j'étais vraiment
dedans et là maintenant j'ai une envie
de revenir et on sera également avec
Tanguy for Jah le coach de Marvin petit
Tanguy ce grand retour de Marvin ou
l'espérée ou l'attendiez espérer espère
toujours c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
remplit des salles qui qui peut faire
bouger le public parce qu'il a une box
atypique et qui tue le public se met
debout quand il box donc oui il y a
beaucoup de gens qui attendent son
retour c'est sûr
hommage à Djibril on disait tout à
l'heure une marche blanche s'est
déroulée hier à Coignières vous étiez
présente en Guy forroger ça vous tenait
à cœur de participer à cet hommage c'est
un petit qui faisait partie de la salle
c'est
un petit qui est bon qui était voilà un
petit un petit un ado quoi rien de
méchant on s'attendait pas qui qui un
jour il se passe un truc comme ça bon
on va pas revenir dessus voilà c'est dû
c'est difficile aussi bien pour la
famille que pour nous plus pour la
famille je pense mais à 14 ans on mérite
pas ça et il faut
il faut rendre hommage ouais il faut
rendre hommage il faut montrer que on
est là aussi voilà l'occasion d'en
reparler tout à l'heure avec un
reportage qui a été réalisé lors de la
Marche Blanche vous étiez d'ailleurs
présent sur place Mickael el midoro à
suivre également les informations du
jour avec vous réginera les bonsoir
quelles sont les actualités de ce lundi
alors plusieurs choses au programme on
parlera notamment d'Éric Ciotti le
nouveau président du parti les
républicains nous reviendra également
sur une action coup de poing menée ce
week-end par des militants yvelinois
contre des panneaux publicitaires mais
ce sera à suivre dans un instant au
programme également au cours de la
prochaine heure zoom sur une boutique
solidaire qui est installée à but
qu'elle a été lancé il y a un an et
l'offre une seconde vie aux objets à des
tarifs très accessibles et toujours à
but nous vous ferons découvrir le
floorball avec un tournoi de la
discipline qui avait lieu ce weekend
dans la commune mais avant tout cela
petit coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
il fera très froid demain à donliez
Yvelines le ciel sera voilé sur
l'ensemble du territoire sauf dans le
sud des Yvelines et les températures
seront négatives moins 3 degrés sur tout
le département le thermomètre qui
restera en dessous des 0 degrés à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi il fera 0°
à Mantes-la-Jolie Oudon et Versailles
bonne nouvelle le soleil sera de la
partie et ce mardi 13 décembre nous
fêterons les Lucie
[Musique]
et on passe tout de suite aux
informations du jour avec vous Régin
ralès et on débute avec un mot de
politique les adhérents les républicains
étaient appelés au vote ce week-end ils
ont choisi le président de leur partie
et ses Éric ciotiques qui a remporté le
scrutin avec
53,7% des suffrages face à Bruno
Retailleau Michel Laugier sénateur des
Yvelines apparentés Union centriste
réagit à l'élection du député des
Alpes-Maritimes il était l'invité de
Patrice Carnoux dans l'émission PAF
je ne suis pas l'air donc c'était une
élection interne alors cioti est sorti
il a pas il a fait un score
53,15 donc c'est pas mal mais
ça veut dire qu'il y a deux courants
très forts au sein des LR et Bruno
Retailleau que je connais bien que je
côtoie au quotidien a fait aussi une
très belle campagne moi ce qui m'importe
aujourd'hui c'est pas de savoir qui est
président qui qui est président DLR et
c'est ce surtout qui va rassembler qui
va rassembler parce que moi je ne crois
que aujourd'hui au rassemblement
d'ailleurs on a toujours gagné dans le
rassemblement dans les périodes
anciennes le RP et l'UDF était ensemble
quand on voulait gagner ça a été pareil
aussi dans des élections départementales
régionales voire locale donc moi je ne
crois qu'au rassemblement et aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce qu'on était à la tête
d'un parti que on va réussir la seule
réussite pour moi ça sera la personne
qui aura un vrai projet et qui sera
capable de rassembler je vous rappelle
aussi que il une autre élection dans un
parti cent triste c'est Hervé Marseille
donc le président du groupe 1h sont
triste dans lequel je siège au Sénat qui
a été élu président de l'UDI je connais
Hervé lui aussi il est pour le
rassemblement donc j'attends le
rassemblement
les images du jour c'est l'apparition
c'est la réapparition du gel dans les
Yvelines avec des températures négatives
et ce même dans l'après-midi regardez ce
bassin recouvert de glace dans le parc
des sources de la Bièvre à Guyancourt
comme vous le disiez Grégory les
températures ne devraient pas remonter
cette semaine il est même prévu quelques
flocons de neige mercredi jeudi et
dimanche l'image du jour tourner à aigu
en cours le chiffre du jour c'est 154
154 c'est le nombre d'orphelins qui vont
bénéficier d'une soirée de charité à
Mantes-la-Jolie c'est l'association les
mamans du ciel qui est derrière cette
initiative la soirée principalement
tournée vers les enfants qui ont perdu
leur mère dans un féminicite se tiendra
le 17 décembre prochain et dernière et
derrière les fourneaux Brahim burkia le
gérant du kebab l'étoile de Fès à
Mantes-la-Jolie cuisinera des burgers
gratuitement on revient à présent régime
sur une opération coup de poing c'est à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux que l'action a eu
lieu des militants d'extinction
rébellion Yvelines est Sud et du
collectif de réappropriation de espace
public de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines un
végétalisé des écrans publicitaires elle
se trouvait au niveau du carrefour des
avenues Gustave Eiffel du centre et du
boulevard Vauban l'intervention a été
interrompue par les forces de l'ordre
pour terminer de la culture on parle de
musique avis aux amateurs et aux
passionnés de musique la batterie offre
une belle opportunité celle de monter
sur scène la salle guyancourtoise lance
un appel pour jouer le 21 janvier
prochain trois groupes se succéderont
vous avez jusqu'au 7 janvier pour vous
inscrire à l'adresse suivante studio
point la batterie
advilencourt.fr et un dernier concert
pour terminer celui de Dana sciocarli
l'artiste propose un récital de piano le
13 décembre prochain au PEC elle jouera
notamment des pièces
issues des folklores régionaux de l'Est
en ouest et deux pièces de Jean-Pierre
Armanet le père de Juliette Armanet un
cancer de Noël quelques jours avant les
vacances c'est à 20h30 au quai 3 merci
Régine et si vous aussi près de chez
vous êtes témoin d'un fait d'actualité
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news
l'information de ce week-end on vous en
parlait dans les titres c'est cette
marche blanche organisée hier dimanche
entre Coignières et Maurepas un moment
de paix pour rendre hommage à Djibril ce
jeune adolescent de 14 ans a été
assassiné lors d'une rixe dans la nuit
du 26 au 27 novembre dernier devant le
gymnase du moulin à vent à Coignières on
garde le reportage de Michael ennemie
Doro et de Nicolas dandry vous vivez les
mêmes galères
les mêmes choses le quotidien il est pas
facile émotion incompréhension et
prévention la maman de Djibril a tenu à
s'adresser aux jeunes qu'il soit de mort
pas de Coignières ou encore de la
verrière ils sont tous touchés par la
disparition de son fils de 14 ans
assassiné il y a deux semaines il a
grandi ici son père il a grandi à
Élancourt son grand-père il habite à la
verrière et il a des cousins à Trappes
donc il a des copains partout partout la
des copains de Djibril et il a pas il
avait pas de problème
particulière avec les autres pour rendre
hommage à son enfant il marche blanche a
été organisée au départ du gymnase du
moulin à vent à Coignières jusqu'au
stade du bois à Maurepas plus de 1000
personnes ont participé à ce moment de
recueillement mais je le connaissais
ouais on se voyait tous les jours je
vais donner des conseils je lui crier
dessus voilà je suis ami avec son père
le jeune je le connais pas
personnellement mais j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont amies avec lui qui sont
danseurs avec moi un soutien à la
famille parce que ce qui s'est passé
franchement c'est inadmissible un jeune
de 14 ans qui est décédé franchement
c'est c'est
une imaginable une atmosphère
silencieuse calme et apaisée entourée ce
rendez-vous en présence des mers des
deux communes liées par ce drame mais il
suffit pas de dire plus jamais ça pour
que ça n'arrive plus il faut
effectivement mettre en place les
mesures qui s'imposent et il faut
effectivement que l'éducation je l'ai
dit dans mon discours il faut que
l'éducation redevienne véritablement la
priorité des priorités parce que ce
n'est que parler d'éducation que nous en
sortirons c'est pas par la répression on
le sait très bien pour rappel
l'adolescent a été tué lors d'une rixe
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 novembre devant
le gymnase du moulin à vent en marge
d'un événement de MMA
et deux invités m'ont rejoint en plateau
pour revenir sur cette marche hommage en
la mémoire de Djibril tinoloco et eryad
betaieb bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
merci d'être présent vous étiez tous les
deux dans l'organisation de cette marche
blanche qui s'est déroulée hier entre
les communes de Coignières est Maurepas
vous êtes tous les deux habitants de la
commune de Maurepas déjà quand vous
voyez ces images c'est plus de 1000
personnes qui étaient présentes hier
pour honorer la mémoire de Djibril et
qui ont participé à cette marche ça vous
fait quoi Tino ben ça fait bah déjà
premièrement ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir d'être soutenu il y avait les
mères un peu des communes
avoisinantes qui ont qui ont participé à
cette marche blanche ça fait du bien
quand même en tant que jeune du quartier
des friches de sentir que voilà on est
on est pas tout seul dans ce drame après
ce drame c'était un moment d'apaisement
c'est ça faisait du bien dit Tino vous
êtes dans du même avis
et pour moi c'était une bonne chose de
se retrouver pour pour se recueil pour
que vous étiez vous le maître de
cérémonie de cette marche blanche
pourquoi c'était important de
l'organiser cette marche pour
sensibiliser un peu
notre secteur dans le 78 parce que
ce qui se passe entre les villes de
Maurepas et de Coignières ça concerne
pas que c'est des villes là il y a eu
aussi beaucoup de
on va dire de guerre entre bande rivale
sur trappes sur les villes comme
Saint-Cyr et
c'était une bonne occasion de de se
faire entendre parce qu'on veut que que
ça cesse ça s'est organisé regarde assez
facilement avec avec les mairies avec
aussi la famille très rapidement moins
d'une semaine et on a su avoir le
soutien de la mairie et des forces de
l'ordre aussi hier qui qui ont su gérer
la marche blanche et le message à faire
passer après deux semaines après ce
drame c'était l'appel apaisement c'est
c'est ça le maître mot hier soir
et surtout qu'on puisse être
entendu au niveau des municipalités
si c'est possible et vous avez le
sentiment que le message a été entendu
hier aussi bien au premier municipalité
peut-être aussi auprès des jeunes qui
voilà sont été directement impliqués
dans automatiquement après le drame nous
on passe au pas une fin en fait la
situation et puis on parle aux jeunes
dans les quartiers parce que en fait on
va pas que pointer du doigt du doigt la
mairie si un problème dans nos quartiers
c'est que voilà il y a des manquements
aussi de notre côté donc on a passé le
message aux jeunes et voilà on essaie de
de le passer à
on va dire à tous les les responsables
c'est quoi les manquements à votre avis
aujourd'hui et à nous si nous riades
déjà de trouver pourquoi du comment ce
jour-là est arrivé le drame battu du
jeune Djibril que ça s'est déroulé dans
la dans la nuit du 26 au 27 novembre
c'était en marche d'un événement MMA
justement le gymnase du moulin à vent
alors la mère de Djibril a rappelé
d'ailleurs pendant ce temps dans sa
prise de parole que finalement c'est ces
jeunes bien issus de quartier peut-être
rival sur le sur rivaux sur le papier
mais vivait les mêmes situations au
quotidien situation difficile ça c'est
aussi important de le préciser ce sont
des jeunes qui vivent le même quotidien
bien sûr bien sûr c'est ça en fait c'est
nous comme on dit dans le quartier c'est
la galère en fait qui fait ça le fait de
galérer en bas du quartier tu as pas
forcément les bonnes idées et
voilà pour rien vous vous retrouvez à
vous taper dessus alors que vous vivez
la même situation donc c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire passer comme messagère
on a demandé au maire qu'on puisse
adapter en fait les méthodes en fonction
de la jeunesse qu'il y a actuellement
dans les quartiers parce que souvent
dans les maisons de jeunesse les
programmes qu'on nous propose c'est des
programmes qui étaient propices mais
pour les années qui sont passées la
jeunesse elle a changé en fait et c'est
ce qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faut faire
passer comme message je pense les
associations en rôle important à jouer
aussi sur sur cet aspect on recevait
tout à l'heure on le recevra également
tout à l'heure tant qu'il Fauga de la
team fort audio qui qui reçoit aussi ces
jeunes au sein de ce club de boxe il y a
aussi les associations qu'on leur rôle à
jouer dans les associations elles ont
leur rôle à jouer ça c'est clair et net
et nous aussi de notre côté on fait le
nécessaire il y a dans dans ce quartier
là il y a un jeune qui avait pris
l'initiative aussi de prendre des jeunes
et tous les encadrer aussi dans la boxe
dans le quartier des friches on a eu
beaucoup de reportages qui sont venus
pour pour découvrir en fait quelle
qualité ce mouvement et ça avait le
petit Djibril il faisait partie des
précurseurs en fait de de
ce de ce mouvement là et c'est pour ça
que ça ça nous touche c'est
dans votre voie c'est n'avant parce que
on avait commencé on avait commencé un
travail au niveau de la jeunesse et la
réalité nous a rapidement rattrapé
peut-être aussi des grands frères c'est
un peu aussi le rôle que vous pouvez
avoir et on l'imagine aussi est très
important pour parler auprès de ces gens
et puis on a on a entamé quelque chose
et puis malheureusement il nous a coûté
nous a quittés en cours de chemin
Régine khalès qui est toujours avec nous
la rédaction tv70 vous avez peut-être
une question à poser oui mais par
rapport justement à ces méthodes que
vous souhaitez adapter comment est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous avez des idées
par rapport à ça
premièrement moi je pense qu'il faudrait
d'abord donner la parole aux jeunes pour
savoir en fait qu'est-ce qu'ils
aimeraient faire parce que nous on leur
propose des programmes mais on sait pas
en fait ce qu'ils aiment faudrait les
découvrir d'abord apprendre à faire
connaissance avec avec eux pour pouvoir
leur proposer des activités qui vont
dans leur sens aussi et leur donner la
parole par exemple sur sur des plateaux
de télévision à la radio dans dans des
temps organisés par des associations ce
serait ce serait ça pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas là où on fait les entendre
où ils peuvent nous faire part de leurs
attentes aussi et ce sera ma dernière
question ça a été aussi rappelé hier
dans les différentes prises de parole
peut-être que l'État doit investir
davantage dans dans les quartiers
notamment en matière d'éducation et ce
qu'ils ont le sentiment ces jeunes
est-ce que vous allez le sentiment
d'être un peu les oublier de la
République et qu'il faut en faire
davantage aujourd'hui mais clairement
clairement on est on est on est on est
délaissés on est délaissé là c'est
vraiment c'est un appel à l'aide
d'investissement dans les quartiers et
puis
il y a pas assez d'attention fait par le
gouvernement ou même les mairies etc
pour les quartiers il faut que davantage
soit fait pour éviter à nouveau ce genre
de drame exactement mais merci à vous
deux Riyad betaia Bettino loco d'être
venu au lendemain de cette marche
blanche on le rappelle qui s'est
déroulée entre Coignières et Maurepas en
la mémoire de Djibril ce jeune qui a été
tué il y a deux semaines au cours d'une
Rix merci d'avoir été avec nous chaque
année un Français jetterais en moyenne
573 kg de déchets parmi les objets mis à
la poubelle beaucoup pourraient avoir
une deuxième vie c'est ce que tente
d'offrir à ses objets une boutique
installée à but l'association Les
Ateliers du kiosque solidaire l'a lancé
il y a un an dans la commune peluche
accessoires décoratif mais aussi
chaussures et les dons reç sont ensuite
proposés à des tarifs solidaires à tous
les publics Julien Leroy avis ho chineur
la boutique de l'association Les
Ateliers du kiosque solidaire a ouvert
ses portes à Buc en décembre 2021 livre
vaisselle jouet ou encore textile les
habitants peuvent venir donner les
articles dont il ne se servent plus ils
seront ensuite proposés à des prix
solidaires généralement divisées par 3
ou 4 comparés au tarif d'origine pendant
le confinement les gens se sont mis à
beaucoup beaucoup triés et jetés des CD
de trouver un
une solution à la gestion des
encombrants dans cette résidence ou dans
une autre résidence donc j'en ai parlé
au bailleur social
qui m'a mise en relation avec la peste
qui est une structure qui accompagne les
créateurs de projet suite à sa demande
Maria obtient ce local de 60 mètres
carrés son objectif éviter à des objets
souvent en bon état de se retrouver
inutilement à la poubelle en outre faire
de ce lieu un endroit convivial pour
créer du lien social c'est pas une
occupation
c'est quelque chose qui permet de faire
avancer les choses au niveau humain au
niveau social au niveau même de tout ce
qui est la nature aussi puisque si on
jette pas et qu'on peut faire autre
chose avec
tout le monde y est tout le monde y
gagne en fait une dizaine de bénévoles
aide au tri au nettoyage et à la
valorisation des dons reçus des objets
uniques pour le plus grand plaisir des
chineur elle nous y trouvons des jeux
pour les enfants ça les occupe le
mercredi déjà il choisit ce même ce
qu'ils veulent c'est beaucoup moins cher
et ça permet de faire un petit un petit
cadeau j'ai profité du week-end pour
faire du tri et pour revaloriser les
objets dont je me servais plus c'est
bien d'aider les autres et comme on peut
avoir besoin d'aide à n'importe quel
moment de notre vie en fait si vous
souhaitez dénicher ces objets de seconde
main la boutique est ouverte à tous les
mercredis jeudi et samedi de 14h à 18h
elle est pris à la consommation ont
augmenté de 6,2% en octobre sur un an
révélait l'Insee récemment face à
l'inflation galopante des solutions
locales et yvelinoise existent exemple
dans le 7 8 avec la Coop Villa Rose elle
est installée au cœur du quartier de
Villaro à Guyancourt cette boutique a
ouvert en mai dernier et elle est donc
bio et coopérative elle propose plus de
4000 références avec des produits
notamment
issus du commerce équitable et je le
disais une ouverture en mai avec aussi
une offre qui est proposée pour les
clients c'est une offre à prix coûtant
pour permettre au plus grand nombre de
consommer des produits bio et de qualité
pour en parler Mathieu Decroix est avec
nous en plateau bonsoir vous êtes
cogérant de la Coop villaroisse déjà
offre à prix coûtant pour que tous les
téléspectateurs comprennent qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire concrètement comment ça
fonctionne c'est simplement on revend le
produit au prix auquel on l'a acheté un
autre fournisseur pourquoi c'est
important pour vous de mettre en place
ce type d'offres bah c'est clairement
fait une démarche enfin politique en
fait qui a derrière
parmi d'autres mais celle-ci en fait
partie c'est le l'idée c'est qu'on
la bio se démocratise mais pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui il y a encore
trop trop de personnes qui n'ont pas les
moyens de simplement de d'acheter des
produits bio et de qualité et nous ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'est
on est parti du constat qu'on peut pas
faire de prix différents à la tête du
client donc ce qu'on s'est dit bah on va
faire une offre à prix coûtant sur un
petit périmètre de produit dans un
premier temps qu'on a déjà augmenté
depuis l'ouverture et on va expliquer à
nos clients bah voilà le New pour
financer cette offre on a besoin
d'augmenter un petit peu donc de 0,3% en
l'occurrence le prix des autres produits
en magasin c'était ma question c'est en
augmentant le prix sur d'autres produits
vous arrivez sur l'ensemble des autres
produits on a augmenté en moyenne de
0,3% ce qui est pas grand chose en soi
mais par contre ça permet aujourd'hui on
a 40 produits de première nécessité donc
du riz de la farine des pâtes on a même
un peu de vin un peu de chocolat de
voilà enfin tout un tout un panier assez
complet de aujourd'hui a pris coûtant et
donc on qui sont vendus en moyenne 30%
moins cher que dans n'importe quel
commerce bio mais c'est ça 30 produits à
la base mais qui ont été augmentés
depuis c'est ça aujourd'hui une
quarantaine de produits environ au mois
de septembre on a on n'est pas 50
produits et là en janvier on est en
train de travailler pour augmenter
l'offre encore à 55 produits donc on
continuera de le faire en fait tant que
nos clients continueront de jouer le jeu
c'est à dire ceux qui ont un peu plus de
moyens privilégie les autres produits
ceux qui ont un peu moins de moyens bah
privilégié davantage ces produits là et
donc c'est cette mixité en fait de
comportement qui permet à l'offre d'être
enfin pérenne économiquement quoi donc
l'idée c'est de l'enrichir encore plus
on continuera jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce
que les ce qu'on atteigne un équilibre
économique qui fait que on peut pas
aller au-delà quoi est-ce que c'est une
offre qui est plébiscité du coup par par
vos clients alors aujourd'hui oui elle
est on voit clairement dans les dans les
ventes le au départ c'était un petit peu
les gens ils étaient hésitants certains
n'osaient pas prendre ses produits de
peur de conditions
après nous apparemment on a rendu tout
le monde à l'aise en disant bah voilà
enfin c'est là sa disposition de tout le
monde chacun fait comme il le souhaite
même si vous pensez avoir plus de moyens
que d'autres et que vous prenez un
produit ou vous regardera pas de travers
donc vraiment on a mis essayer de mettre
à l'aise les gens qui soient aisés ou
moins aisés et puis bah maintenant c'est
devenu un il y a des gens qui viennent
que pour ça d'autres qui nous prennent
jamais ces produits spécifiquement pour
soutenir la démarche du magasin et donc
voilà sur cette mixité qui est
qui est bien enfin qui est super
agréable pour nous de voir parce que ben
on constate que bah qu'on donne les
moyens aux gens de d'essayer de
rééquilibrer un peu les choses dans
dans ces problématiques de pouvoir
d'achat de justice sociale et c'est
voilà on sait pas une obligation pour se
nourrir correctement de en tout cas pour
se nourrir d'acheter des premiers prix
industriels de mauvaise qualité nous on
peut on a 40 produits bio de qualité 30
% moins cher qu'ailleurs donc je vous
disais des produits de base on retrouve
dans cette offre originaleh peut-être
une question en fait cette méthode assez
innovante où vous est venue l'idée de
mettre cette méthode en place
l'idée c'était
nous en fait on a créé le magasin c'est
l'idée c'est pas juste de vendre des
produits
c'est pas notre métier au départ
et
à travers le magasin en fait on fait on
veut vraiment essayer de transformer de
transformer les choses quoi et la vision
que peuvent avoir les gens sur le bio
sur la coopération ce qui est vraiment
enfin fait partie de la dame du magasin
et donc nous on a une coopérative en
tant que entreprise mais on essaie aussi
de de faire coopérer nos clients entre
eux donc c'est un peu la solidarité
quelque part entre nos clients qui fait
que ces produits là sont économiquement
viables pour nous même si on les vend
sont en gagner enfin rien du tout et en
même temps permettent d'avoir une offre
qu'on arrive enrichir en plus
donc voilà l'idéal est venue parce que
c'est bah c'est un projet politique on
fait on fait du bio on fait du local on
fait de l'équitable on fait du prix
coûtant on fait beaucoup de vrac zéro
déchet voilà enfin c'est on essaie de
développer vraiment toutes ces démarches
toute une démarche et autour de la
coopération aussi donc l'entreprise est
une SCOP une coopérative de salariés
c'est à dire que tous les salariés ont
une voix dans les instances
décisionnelles de l'entreprise quel que
soit leur rapport en capital
c'est-à-dire que c'est si Intel a mis
que 5 euros et l'autre a mis 20000 euros
les deux ont le même pouvoir en fait
dans l'entreprise et sont rémunérés de
la même manière il y a la c'est un
système égalitaire enfin pur et dur qui
est encadré par la loi il y a un droit
coopératif et on disait tout à l'heure
donc a ouvert cette boutique depuis mai
donc dans le quartier de Villeroy à
Guyancourt plus de 4000 références sur
place on peut faire toutes ses courses
sur place
d'avoir un magasin taille humaine mais
où tous les tous les besoins
alimentaires et non alimentaires donc
sur l'entretien les cosmétiques sont
couverts donc on n'a pas 50 choix dessus
50 chevaux de farine mais par contre on
a tous les types de farine et tous les
enfin on peut faire toutes nos courses
toutes ces courses au magasin clairement
combien de membres dans l'équipe
aujourd'hui là on est quatre à plein
temps et on a deux étudiantes qui nous
accompagnent le samedi et
voilà à côté de ça donc on a une
association de soutien qui nous aide
aussi sur des actions bénévoles de
tractage pour nous faire connaître ou de
qui organise des animations en magasin
genre des choses et vous êtes ouvert six
jours sur 7 voilà pour toutes les
informations et d'ailleurs il y a le
site internet de la COP villaroisse qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour pour
plus d'informations merci à vous Mathieu
Decroix d'être venu en plateau je le
rappelle cogéant et de la Coop
villaroise installée dans le quartier de
Villaroy à Guyancourt et d'autres
structures yvelinoise se mobilisent
contre l'inflation c'est le cas aussi
par exemple avec Guyancourt de la map
des saules elle propose à ses membres
une tarification juste et adaptée au
niveau de vie de chacun a des adhérents
et permet de soutenir dans le même temps
le maraîcher dans son activité un plus
informations également sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de la page sport dans
l'émission Le 7 8 avec le retour en
plateau de Michel et le Migros
n'ayez pas peur n'ayez pas peur de moi
avec l'actualité de ce weekend il va au
sport c'était c'est quart de finale de
la Coupe du monde de football avec la
France avec la France qui a brillé qui a
gagné deux buts face à l'Angleterre on
l'a tous eu un je crois 18 millions de
Français ont vu ce match à la télévision
et il y a eu aussi la victoire du Maroc
un peu plus surprenante la victoire du
Maroc en tout cas on a pu suivre ces
deux exploits dans les Yvelines et
forcément il y a eu beaucoup d'ambiance
un reportage de m'a dit de Franco
qui était sur place
Yvelines c'était à Poissy et attrape où
on regarde tout de suite ce reportage
sur la joie des supporters des Bleus et
des supporters du Maroc dans les
Yvelines
une Marseillaise pour commencer une
nouvelle soirée historique pour le
football français plusieurs dizaines de
supporters des Bleus ont décidé de
donner de la voie au forum Armand
Peugeot de Poissy lors de ce quart de
finale contre l'Angleterre puis soudain
à la 17e minute de jeu Aurélien
ivre de bonheur les pissé
1-0 ce sera le score à la pose on a
maîtrisé le ballon bon les Anglais ont
été un peu dangereux mais on a réussi à
marquer tôt donc on aurait plutôt pas
mal pour la deuxième mi-temps
après ce qui compte c'est le travail en
équipe et je crois qu'on a su mettre
l'intensité qu'il fallait dans les duels
pour pouvoir se projeter vers l'avant et
marquer le but qu'il nous faut pour la
victoire refroidi par légalisation
anglaise en début de seconde période les
supporters français continuent d'y
croire et la libération arrivera la 78e
minute grâce à un but de Giroud après
quelques frayeurs les Français sont en
demi-finale de la 22e Coupe du Monde
soulagée et c'est mérité des soldats on
a été combatifs si il se méritait quand
même très content c'était compliqué mais
on l'a fait c'était compliqué mais c'est
ce qui rend la Coupe du Monde
intéressante à regarder mais finalement
ça finit bien Harry Kane il a pas
l'habitude de louper des peaux il a
loupé le peno c'est parfait quelques
heures plus tôt ce sont les supporters
marocains qui ont exulté dans ce bar
portugais situé près de la mairie de
Trappes
au Maroc s'impose face au Portugal sur
le score de 1 à 0 direction les
demi-finales une première pour un Club
Africain inch'Allah on va partir on va
en prendre
oui
après une nuit avec des scènes de liesse
aux quatre coins du département
supporter français et marocain se
retrouveront ce mercredi 14 décembre à
20h pour cette demi-finale déjà
historique que le meilleur gagne
on est déjà projeté sur cette
demi-finale France Maroc et Poissy va
d'ailleurs retransmettre de nouveau le
match au forum Armand Peugeot Michael il
sera retransmis aussi dans nombreux bars
ils disent non on l'imagine vous allez
le regarder ce match alors je vais le
regarder alors chez moi pour le coup
parce qu'on a une petite tradition entre
amis depuis le début de la compétition
le premier match contre l'Australie on
le regarde tous ensemble donc l'idée
c'est de faire toute la compétition
ensemble et on est un peu superstitieux
donc on est unit jusqu'à la fin on va
faire un petit tour de table auprès de
nos invités marine petit étang Guy
forruggets qui sont venus en plateau
vous allez regarder ce match est-ce que
ça vous intéresse la Coupe du monde
même samedi on était sur un ring on
regardait entre deux échauffements une
passe ou deux on n'a pas pu regarder
depuis le début de la malheureusement la
période ne prête pas que je puisse
regarder un match malheureusement et
forcément on imagine la France favorite
dans ce match puisqu'elle a quand même
un statut de champion du monde à
défendre et ce que c'est ouvert selon
vous quel est votre pronostic si vous en
avez un avril j'en ai un c'est que ça va
être dur pour la France aussi ils ont
des le Maroc ils ont des gros joueurs et
tout le monde a sous-estimé le varoque
jusqu'ici et ils sont arrivés en
demi-finale donc s'ils sont ici c'est
pas pour rien quoi ok moi je reste
français je reste française bleu blanc
rouge non non je suis pas bah je suis
pour la France maintenant c'est vrai que
jusqu'à maintenant la elle a fait des
expos Maroc
qui fait qui montre les échelons
j'espère que ça va s'arrêter
l'Espagne de du Portugal en face de vous
il y a Jean-Pierre Garcin qui nous a
rejoint bonsoir copilote vous allez
participer dans quelques jours à votre
24e Dakar on va avoir l'occasion d'en
parler mais déjà une petite question sur
France Maroc moi je suis pas passionné
de football mais honnêtement les grands
événements comme ça je les regarde je
l'ai regardé avec plaisir et je trouve
que cette année c'est encore plus il y a
du spectacle il y a du jeu et c'est vrai
que j'ai regardé les matchs du Maroc je
les ai trouvés fabuleux donc j'ai pas de
pronostic parce que je lui dis que ça
sera chaud quand même quoi voilà et on
va parler du Dakar dans un instant un
petit prono avant de passer à autre
chose sur le Dakar ou non
je lui ai dit 2 à 0 quand même pour
l'équipe de France je vois quand même la
France l'emporter mais bon on sait
jamais les Portugais disaient aussi
qu'ils allaient l'emporter donc et les
Espagnols aussi donc on ne sait jamais
en pronostics
voilà je j'ai tendance à prenait skier
le contraire de ce qui va se passer donc
je vais porter malheur à personne et je
m'abstiendrai de faire un pronostic on
va continuer de parler football Mickael
on jouait ce week-end dans les Yvelines
avec des températures quand même un peu
plus fraîches qu'attend oui dans le
championnat de National le FC Versailles
est monté ce week-end le club historique
du Red Star et les Versailles ont réussi
à des accrocher le Red Star sur sa
pelouse le score 0 à 0 classement après
15 juin discuté Versailles et toujours
deuxième du championnat devant son
adversaire du jour
on continue avec le championnat de R3
c'est ça c'est ça exactement Poissy
n'arrive pas à enchaîner après une
défaite contre Vannes une victoire
contre Vannes le week-end dernier
l'épiceaki ont perdu ce week-end sur le
terrain d'Évreux sur le score de 3 à 1
au classement lace Poissy redescend à la
troisième place du championnat derrière
Rouen prochain match pour les Illinois
ce samedi à 18h contre Chartres alors je
suis un peu perdu Michael c'est
maintenant peut-être qu'on va parler du
championnat de régional 3 non c'est pas
du tout on va parler on va parler de la
fédérale 2 là
de fédéral 2 plaisir qui veut monter en
fin de saison c'est imposé dans la
douleur face à Orsay ce dimanche à
domicile le score 29 à 21 pour les
plaisirsois dans l'autre rencontre
Versailles est perdu 30 à 28 sur sa
pelouse contre le leader Le Havre au
classement plaisir est toujours 5e et
Versailles et 7e et on va parler
maintenant de la Régionale 3 la région
A3 c'est moi qui avait un problème de
football
très bien alors dans le championnat de
de R3 mort pas jouer ce week-end sous
les températures glaciales
saint-maurusitanos et les Yvelinois se
sont inclinés 4 à 2 sur leur terrain
menés à 3-0 ils avaient pourtant réussi
à revenir à 3-2 avec une balle de 3 3
ils se sont finalement inclinés 4 à 2
contre Saint-Maur dans les dernières
secondes ce dimanche on écoute le
capitaine de l'équipe maurepasienne ce
qui est bien c'est qu'on a su relever la
tête à 3-0 et revenir à 32 donc
finalement l'état d'esprit n'était pas
si mauvais que ça si on regarde le
classement c'est un mauvais résultat
après on est tombé sur une équipe qui
était pas non plus mauvaise maintenant
on avait un peu un petit matelas avant
avant ce match là on va voir si si il
serait dû encore plus ou si on arrive à
recréer les cartes le prochain match à
la rentrée
merci Mickaël pour cette large page
résultats en continu bien sûr à parler
de sport avant de parler du Dakar dans
un instant on parle de boxe avec nos
invités Marvin petit et Tanguy faroudia
en disait marine petit vous êtes de
retour et vous allez être de retour sur
les rings prochainement Michael vous
vous demandez en début d'édition ça vous
manquait la compétition de revenir sur
les rimes oui ça manquait ça manquait
énormément parce que j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours boxé de ma vie ça fait
exactement 24 ans je box donc
la box c'est c'est Lançon on va dire et
c'est vrai que j'ai arrêté depuis un
moment j'étais un peu nerveux je le
voyais j'étais beaucoup nerveux même sur
le sur les routes et tout ça j'étais
beaucoup nerveux donc là j'ai repris le
sport donc je me sens beaucoup beaucoup
mieux et je pense revenir très très fort
et là je veux monter de catégorie parce
que enneigé j'ai battu tous les
meilleurs en France et aujourd'hui à
plus personne pour moi en France donc je
pense que voilà aujourd'hui j'ai j'avais
défié ils vont Mendy ils vont m'indy qui
était qui était mon challenger officiel
pour le pour le Championnat d'Europe
et depuis le temps il m'évite alors
qu'en gros il veut pas me compter parce
que ici aujourd'hui que simbox c'est je
le mettrai ko c'est sûr et
aujourd'hui je veux faire des défis en
66 kg en Walter je vais monter je vais
monter de catégories en Walter faire des
défis en 66 et les mettre KO aussi donc
qu'est-ce qui vous pousse à revenir vous
l'avez dit c'est c'est le défi
finalement c'est les défis ouais j'aime
les défis moi plus plus fort plus
j'adore j'ai toujours mis les gants que
les clés avec les plus fort que moi et
c'est on va dire c'est plus tu mets des
gants les plus forts plus tu
progresseras
de ce retour de de Marvin quand je vois
quand je le vois sur le ce qu'il y a sur
le ring actuellement enfin sont des
immigrés qui que ce soit Marvin il a
largement sa place voilà que ça soit en
Walter en super Walter c'est malheureux
à dire parce qu'il y a des VDG mais il
peut faire le ménage voilà il a sa place
pour faire ménage voilà il y en a un qui
est champion du monde un Français
IBA dans une fédération pas mon mineur
mais c'est un titre de champion du monde
quand même Marvin je suis sur qui
je suis sorti voilà à Marvin bien près
on était sûr si on nous appelle qu'un
jour avant ça sera un peu dur mais si on
nous laisse deux trois mois de
préparation je suis sûr que Marvin il va
avant la limite voilà est-ce que vous
venez aussi pour vos supporters aussi
Marvin on sait que vous déplacez les
foules on l'a dit tout à l'heure cette
émission c'est aussi pour vos superteurs
je reçois beaucoup beaucoup de messages
sur les sur les réseaux sur les
Instagram les réseaux Facebook snapchat
et tout ça quand est-ce que je reviens
il y en a beaucoup depuis deux ans et
demi on m'a toujours des messages et
genre j'ai dit j'en faisais promis que
j'allais revenir bon j'ai pas eu
l'occasion parce que j'étais avec ma
société j'étais beaucoup pris avec la
couleur de couverture mais aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de revenir et j'ai envie de
faire comme il dit j'ai envie de faire
le tri dans le 66 kg comme ça j'aurai
fait le tri aussi en 66
et je sais et en ce moment je me sens
beaucoup plus fort qu'avant parce que
voilà j'ai la maturité j'ai l'expérience
et je sais que maintenant j'ai un peu
mon sérieux que qui est derrière
votre bilan c'est 25 victoires un nulle
une défaite c'est bien ça Tanguy le
disait avec de l'entraînement avec des
formations
de robe du monde que qui était serré et
une défaite où on m'a volé en Belgique
pour le chauffage donc pour la précision
et du coup vous allez le sentiment que
vous pouvez aller chercher un titre
mondial avec la préparation nécessaire
ouais bien sûr bien sûr en fait il faut
mettre en place une structure
aujourd'hui on va plus faire ça à
l'aveuglette on va mettre une structure
et faire un compte préparation à 100%
vous donnez combien de temps
peut-être aller chercher ce titre de
champion
si on propose le combat mais aujourd'hui
en fait moi on propose jamais on propose
pas parce que aujourd'hui vous avez pas
de combat
programmer on va proposer la
décontrables on m'a appelé on m'a appelé
pour pour boxer et on va proposer comme
toi qui avait dit un titre mondial
un titre mondial pour un championnat du
monde
pour juin donc du coup ben moi je suis
moi je suis partant le mois de juin
Tanguy fawja pour un titre mondial c'est
jouable c'est jouable on va voir ça
dépend comment il va revenir parce que
il va rester trois ans sans rien faire
mais
mais tout est jouable
peut-être dans les prochaines semaines
le plus dur c'est de revenir le plus dur
c'est revenir une fois qu'il aura fait
son premier combat de retour ça ça y est
la machine à remis en place il reste
plus qu'à qu'à ajuster les deux trois
trucs et si c'est pas moi ça sera
peut-être à la rentrée mais il y aura le
Championnat du Monde c'est une question
de
quand je vois il est il est capable
d'être champion du monde et toute la
préparation va se faire à Élancourt
Marvin pour l'instant on reste en cours
tu ne sais pas après on verra au niveau
des paris
on programme ça moi ce que je veux c'est
les meilleurs sparines et je veux pas je
veux pas disparing on va dire qui sont
en dessous de moi je vais disparaître
qui est beaucoup plus dur que moi et que
je me sens en difficulté et que je sais
que je peux surmonter ça
en tout cas merci Marvin petit merci à
Tanguy fortugel on va suivre bien sûr
avec attention la suite de votre
carrière on vous souhaite bien sûr le
titre mondial pourquoi pas en juin on va
suivre ça bien sûr avec attention
à Djibril merci d'être venu tous les
deux en plateau et on continue de parler
sport avec vous Jean-Pierre Garcin et je
le disais alors le 31 décembre prochain
vous allez prendre le départ du rallye
red Dakar 2023 une course qui sera
organisée jusqu'au 15 janvier et ce sera
votre 24e participation en tant que
copilote pourquoi ça vous plaît tant
cette course du Dakar c'est une
rencontre le premier Dakar ça a été par
hasard et après c'est la passion quoi
tous les ans on y va et à chaque fois on
revient et on se pose même pas de
question quoi même là je commence à être
vieux et je me pose pas de question je
repense toujours à repartir l'année
d'après donc on structure notre année en
vérité par rapport à cet événement et on
cherche quelque chose à faire voilà et
là cette année
choisit un peu un défi avec une équipe
chinoise avec un pilote chinois qui
s'appelle goyoud Zang voilà c'est ça que
je connais parce que j'ai fait quelques
courses en Chine et bon bah c'est la
communication qui sera le plus dur mais
ça sera pas la première fois que je
roulais avec un pilote chinois et en fin
de compte 40 mots nous suffisent à peu
près pour lancer sur qu'on peut pas se
raconter notre vie bon même maintenant
il y a des super traducteurs donc dans
la voiture je suis sûr que en liaison
etc me racontera sa vie je suis pas
inquiet mais bon avec 40 mots on va se
débrouiller voilà alors depuis deux mois
là il s'est mis à prendre l'anglais
parce que du coup ah ça sera en anglais
ça sera en anglais le roadbook de toute
façon est en anglais quoi toutes les
infos que je donne moi sont anglais donc
c'est pas trop le problème quoi j'espère
qu'il les a apprises mais
malheureusement avec la le problème des
covid est encore chez eux ils ont du mal
à se déplacer même c'est très difficile
donc on s'est pas rencontré encore cette
année on va se rencontrer le 27 décembre
ou le 28 décembre c'est un peu spécial
finalement à distance à distance quoi
voilà distance mais
c'est des gens que j'aime bien
honnêtement c'est des gens que je
connais pour qui j'ai déjà travaillé
voilà c'est lui qui m'a fait un appel du
pied ça fait c'est son ça sera son
troisième Dakar c'est un jeune j'ai même
pas quel âge honnêtement mais je suis
pas inquiète du tout quoi voilà c'est un
bon pilote chinois quoi en tout cas quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui aime qui a une bonne
valeur et ben son premier Dakar il a
fini 14e donc voilà et on voit la
voiture dans laquelle vous avez
participé à un mot sur sur cette voiture
c'est une bonne voiture c'est une très
bonne voiture alors c'est un
constructeur chinois alors
qui qui vient petit à petit plus de plus
en plus officiellement quoi et c'est une
très bonne voiture c'est une voiture
on peut raisonnablement penser qu'on va
rentrer entre 10 et 15 quoi à la fin du
Dakar si tout va bien quoi on lance donc
ça serait j'aimerais bien qu'il fasse
une meilleure place avec moi que ce
qu'il a fait déjà ce serait valorisant
et puis pourquoi pas avancer parce que
il y a eu la création d'un championnat
du monde l'année dernière d'un vrai
championnat du monde des filles a avec
as promoteur et ça donne un peu
dynamique dans la discipline bon alors
ça serait bien que les gens suivent
parce que ça se fait pas sans
constructeur ça se fait pas son
concurrent il y a cinq courses à l'année
prochaine on aura une a du bail une
au Mexique une en Argentine et une au
Maroc avec le Dakar et le Dakar c'est la
première épreuve de ce fameux
championnat donc ça serait bien que tout
le monde s'investisse mais alors même
c'est pas facile mais aujourd'hui mais
non il faut y croire quoi voilà donc on
va commencer par le Dakar votre meilleur
performance c'est 6e du Dakar est-ce que
vous pouvez peut-être dans un futur
proche être sur le podium je sais pas
moi je suis poli imaginer alors non
parce que moi je suis plus proche de la
retraite que du début mais mais c'est
pas très grave non non les gens
heureusement il y a des jeunes qui sont
arrivés qui sont performants il y en a
qui poussent et c'est très bien quoi
franchement voilà non non moi je vais
rester à essayer de rester entre 10 et
20 ça sera très bien et puis voilà mais
bon si j'ai pas
j'avais commencé à travailler pour
l'organisation du silkwarelli qui était
un rallye en Russie on allait en Chine
tout ça ça fait deux ans que je
travaillais malheureusement avec les
événements tout s'est arrêté je cherche
un moyen de continuer voilà différemment
mais bon aujourd'hui je suis encore en
forme voilà je la pêche j'ai encore
envie de faire copilote je me pose pas
de question bon copilote quels sont ces
missions que doit-il faire un bon
copilote en gros tout le monde se perd
voilà c'est on se retrouve le plus
facilement c'est plus celui qui se
retrouve le plus facilement qui est le
meilleur enfin voilà tout le monde se
perd parce que les informations en plus
maintenant on a les informations
en flash instantané parce qu'on a une
tablette et on n'a pas d'informations on
peut pas préparer avant le parcours on
peut pas voir notre book c'est se
remettre avant le départ le notre
tablette s'allume avec le rebook et le
readbook va défiler toute la journée et
c'est un peu notre Bible c'est moi j'ai
mis le roadbook et j'essaye de
comprendre qu'est-ce qu'on fait quoi
voilà donc quand on se perd ben c'est de
récupérer rapidement et c'est là
heureusement c'est pour les vieux comme
moi c'est beaucoup d'expérience que j'ai
fait des centaines de milliers de
kilomètres dans le désert et le désert
qui soit en Chine en Arabie Saoudite
différents
les couleurs sont les mêmes les
difficultés sont les mêmes donc voilà
c'est la chance ou la discipline permet
à des personnes un petit peu âgées de
continuer match quoi voilà parce que
c'est pas et au contraire un jeune il a
dit il met beaucoup de temps à acquérir
l'expérience et bon il faut passer par
là
il y a une évolution au niveau de
l'organisation du Dakar des informations
c'est le dernier moment bah c'est de
plus en plus professionnel
l'organisation pour éviter le facteur
triche parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui trichaient parce que voilà pour
éviter le facteur triche David castéral
de vos directeur du Dakar depuis 3 ans à
instaurer tout ça justement ces outils
la tablette les informations dernières
minutes on a de moins en moins
d'informations donc on prépare de moins
en moins de choses en vérité quoi mais
c'est bien parce que on a supprimé on
essaye de supprimer le maximum de triche
quoi donc l'épreuve en Arabie Saoudite
encore cette année quels sont les pièges
à éviter quels sont les secteurs les
plus difficiles alors comme d'habitude
ça sera la deuxième semaine et cette
année on va dans une zone qui s'appelle
le petit quarter qui est le long de
Oman de la frontière ou c'est un océan
de dunes de sable donc on va se taper 5
journées de sable et quand on voit la
longueur des étapes qui sont très courts
c'est à dire des étapes avec 200 km tout
ça ça veut dire que c'est très dur voilà
on a vu des photos des reconnaissances
et tout on sait que ça va être très dur
après malheureusement nous on passe au
mois de janvier au mois de janvier il
fait plus frais il y a des risques de
petites pluies donc le sable se comporte
différemment tandis que les gens qui
font le parcours passent au mois de
septembre octobre et il fait encore très
chaud moi j'y étais il y a trois
semaines je fais encore 35 degrés quoi
donc nous peut-être qu'on verra
inch'Allah comme on dit mais bon merci
Jean-Pierre Garcin et on le rappelle le
lors du Dakar 2023 c'est le 31 décembre
prochain et vous allez vous participez
pour la 24e fois au rallye red Dakar on
termine avec une dernière information
Michael une dernière information
sportive il y avait du floorball ce
weekend à bu qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez le floorball Grégory
finalement non autour de 7 ans
de balle voilà ça ressemble plus ou
moins du hockey sur glace mais sans
patins voilà dans un dans un gymnase le
un tournoi de 3e division était organisé
dans la commune de Buc l'occasion de
découvrir ce sport venue des pays
nordiques à un portage de Gabriel
Gontier
un match de hockey sur glace mais dans
un gymnase et sans patins ce dimanche
les équipes de floorball de division 3
de Buc et Damien s'affrontaient lors
d'un grand championnat l'objectif de ce
sport collectif mettre la balle dans le
corps adverse grâce à une crosse
aujourd'hui a Buc c'est un match de
championnat c'est à dire que il y a à
peu près 5 à 6 rencontres par an ou
différentes équipes se réunissent pour
faire un match qui va compter pour le
championnat de Détroit de France né en
Suède la discipline est apparue à Buc il
y a une quinzaine d'années importées par
une entreprise suédoise les jet sabuck
ça a commencé il y a pas mal de temps
pour vous dire il y a une quinzaine
d'années avec Ericsson l'entreprise
d'alexson il est pas mal de suédois qui
venaient en France en expat et les
Suédois ce sont des fans de florball et
il jouait ils ont commencé à jouer en
fait dans les locaux de Rixon le soir et
ils ont vite cherché à trouver un
gymnase gymnase qu'ils ont trouvé à Buc
et c'est là que tout a commencé pour
notre club les jets de Buc sont le seul
club de flamball présente dans les
Yvelines un club en pleine évolution
c'est un sport déjà qui progresse en
France beaucoup dans de plus en plus de
villes et à but aussi notre section
jeune est pleine elle a ouvert il y a 3
ans et elle est pleine depuis 3 ans au
total ils sont une cinquantaine de
licenciés à pratiquer la discipline à
Buc ce dimanche les jets se sont imposés
face à Amiens 4 à 2
voilà pour cette découverte du florball
merci Michael pour toutes ces précisions
demain vous prendrez ma place pour la
présentation du 7 8 et on parlera de
nouveau de sport avec la diagonale des
Yvelines
78 c'est une diagonale une course à pied
un trail qui traversera le département
du Nord au Sud et forcément là aussi il
faut beaucoup de cardio comme on a pu le
voir dans le reportage précédent le
flambole c'est cardio mais le trail
c'est aussi cardio et on aura l'occasion
donc d'en parler demain rendez-vous
demain dans le 7 8 avant de vous laisser
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
un dernier petit tour par la météo de
demain
il faudra très froid demain matin dans
les Yvelines le ciel sera voilée sur
l'ensemble du territoire sauf dans le
sud des Yvelines et les températures
sont négatives - 3 degrés sur tout le
département le thermomètre resteront de
sous à des 0° à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi il fera 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie oudans et Versailles
bonne nouvelle le soleil sera de la
partie ce mardi 13 décembre c'est la
Sainte Lucie voilà c'est la fin de ce 7
8 merci de notre de votre fidélité merci
à nos invités merci à Mickaël et le
midoro d'avoir été avec nous et on se
retrouve dès demain vous retrouverez
Mickaël et midro à ma place pour la
présentation d'une nouvelle édition du 7
8 belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]